يا سادة حين فرقتهم الحرب جمعتهم
المصالح. السوريون والاتراك وعقد
من المعارك والحروب. الضربات لا
تتوقف والهجمات متواصلة. انقرة
تقصف جوا ودمشق ترد على الارض.
اما ان الحرب ان تتوقف؟ سؤال
يطرحه القاصي والداني على هذه
المعمورة. لكن هل سيجيب البلدان
عنه؟ اردوغان يتخلى عن غروره
وسوريا جثة لا تضرها طعنة اخرى
والصلح خير. فهل حان وقت التصالح
يا هؤلاء عن اللحوم السورية
نتحدث؟ وللقصة بقية؟ الجمر يغلي
ونيران الحرب لا تنتهي. ما ان
الجمل السوري حتى حد الجميع
سكاكينهم بانتظار فريسة وقعت
بنفسها دون طعم. بدأت الحرب في
الداخل السوري ونحن نتحدث عن
احداث عام الفين واحد عشر. وما
بعد ذلك ارقام سجلها التاريخ
وتألم لها من بقي على قيد الحياة
من السوريين. فعن اي حياة نتحدث.
هذا الواقع السوري اسال لعاب
الوحوش الخارجية. الولايات
المتحدة هرعت الغرب بقواتها
والقرارات الدولية. والهدف ليس
تأمين البلاد السورية ولكن
اغتنام الثروات والنفط. وليذهب
السوريون الى جحيم الفقر والجوع.
الدب الروسي لن يغمض عينيه عن
محاولة الامريكان السيطرة على
دولة حليفة. السلطان العثماني
بدوره اعد عدته ليقضي مآربه في
الدولة الجارة. وبين هذا وذاك
ايران تواجه تهديد الكيان على
الاراضي السورية. ودمشق تستقبل
ضربات الكيان الجوية باحضان
مفتوحة. فما عاد لديها ما تقاوم
به جوعها حتى تجد ما تصد به
غارات الطائرات. ويا لقساوة
الاقدار. ولنا ان نتخيل العواقب
الوخيمة لهذه الحرب السورية.
وبعد اثني عشر عاما من الاقتتال
الداخلي والضربات الخارجية هناك
اكثر من خمسة ملايين طفل بحاجة
مساعدة داخل سوريا. كثير من
الاطفال ولدوا في الحرب وكثيرون
منهم لا يعرفون الا الحرب. قتل
منهم حوالي تسعمائة طفل في عام
الفين وثمانية عشر وحدة. هذا
الصراع الدائر في سوريا منذ عام
الفين واحد عشر اسفر عن وقوع
خسائر فادحة في الشعب السوري.
حيث قتل اكثر من اربعمائة الف
شخص واضطر اكثر من نصف السكان
الى مغادرة منازلهم في اكبر ازمة
للاجئين منذ الحرب العالمية
الثانية. حرب احرقت الشجر وقتلت
البشر وحطمت الحجر. نعم حتى
الاثر السورية لم يعد لها وجود
بين مدمرة ومسروقة ومنهوبة
ومبيوعة للخارج ليدخل العام
الفين وثلاثة وعشرين بعد حرب
مدمرة في سوريا. ويحيل البلد
السوري الى وطن يستحيل العيش
فيه. فمع كل ذلك لم يبقى اقتصاد
للسوريين ليتكأ عليه فالدولار
الامريكي الواحد بات يعادل اليوم
اكثر من سبعة الاف وثلاثمائة
ليرة سورية. لقد استحالت سوريا
الى الخراب عن بكرة ابيها. على
الرغم من كل تلك الالاعيب. تجد
سوريا نفسها تغرق اليوم في الجوع
والبرد والفقر في ازمة اقتصادية
لم تشهد لها مثيلا تشكل الازمة
اكبر خطر وجودي على البلد في
حدوده الراهنة منذ اتفاق. تصالح
المصالح. بعد قطيعة دامت لاكثر
من احد عشر عاما. بوادر التقارب
تلوح في الافق بين سوريا وتركيا.
انقرة كانت من اوائل من استغلوا
الفوضى السورية لتنقض على
اهدافها في الشمال السوري من جهة
ونقصد هنا الاكراد بينما دعم
الرئيس التركي طيب اردوغان
المعارضة السورية في مواجهة
النظام السوري بقيادة بشار
الاسد. لكن ما بعد الحرب
الاوكرانية ليس كما قبلها. ادرك
اردوجان انه يجب عليه حل القضية
مع سوريا على طاولة الحوار لا
على ارض المعارك. وفي الحقيقة
اردوجان ربما عرف ذلك بعد فوات
الاوان فالانتخابات الرئاسية
التركية على بعد اشهر قليلة.
والداخل التركي يغلي ان انهكت
المعارك السورية الاقتصاد الوطني
واردوغان يبحث عن نصر انتخابي
قبل خوض الاقتراع. هنا وللمرة
الاولى منذ بداية المعارك وزراء
الدفاع ورؤساء الاستخبارات في
اجتماع ثلاثي بين موسكو وانقرة
ودمشق على الاراضي الروسية من
اجل التصالح وما كان مستحيلا
اصبح واقعا. وبعد سنوات من
الجمود السياسي الذي وصل الى حد
العداء بين سوريا وتركيا. ها هي
العلاقات بين البلدين في الايام
الاخيرة تعيش نوعا من الدفئ يمكن
ان يقود في المستقبل القريب الى
لقاء تاريخي بين الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوجان ونظيره السوري
بشار الاسد. لكن هل يترك اردوغان
حلفاءه كالمعارضة السورية? فقد
جمعتهم الحرب ليقترب الصلح من
تفريقهم. هذه المعارضة والثوار
في سوريا وهؤلاء لنظام بشار
الاسد تفرقوا في الحرب لكنهم
اليوم يجتمعون ضد الصلح بين
اردوجان والاسد وخرجت المظاهرات
في عموم البلاد لتندد المعارضة
بمخالفة اردوجان لوعوده معهم.
واردوغان بهذا الصلح يريد اعادة
حوالي اربعة ملايين لاجئ سوري من
بلاده الى وطنهم. ويهدف الى
السيطرة على منطقة امنة بعمق
ثلاثين كيلومتر داخل الاراضي
السورية وبشار الاسد يطلب رحيلا
كاملا للقوات التركية من بلده او
قد يقبل برحيل جزئي ايضا لكن
الولايات المتحدة لا تريد الصلح.
المتحدث باسم الخارجية الامريكية
يقول نحن لا ندعم الدول التي
تعزز علاقاتها او تعرب عن دعمها
لاعادة الاعتبار لبشار الاسد
الديكتاتور الوحشي. بعد من اكثر
من عقد من الزمن تتجه سوريا نحو
الصلح مع تركيا مع رفض امريكي
قاطع لهذه المصالحة. برأيكم هل
يتجاهل الطرفان الولايات
المتحدة؟ ويعقدان صلحا تاريخيا
برعاية روسية؟ وهل ستنعم سوريا
ولو بقليل من الهدوء بعد كل هذا؟